good morning millennials welcome back to
the morning toast happy friday it is a
beautiful stunning and snowy friday here
in new york and it's just a great way to
kick off the weekend hey claudia how are
you doing
i'm doing great because it's
friday friday gotta get down on friday
everybody's looking forward to the
weekend weekend we're getting down on
friday the longest week ever the first
week of the year has come to a close
hope everyone's feeling like it was a
good start to the year you know they say
how you spend the you know whatever is
how you live whatever
i don't think statistically that there's
a longer week and a more treacherous
week than the first week of a new year
and we want to let you know that you are
through it in case you didn't know you
did it so
that's a really big accomplishment i
hope everyone has some really fun
weekend plans in the works what are you
doing this weekend
um well you know i am going to mexico
next week so we'll schedule give you
guys a scheduling update but there's no
show next friday and monday um
so i'm thinking of taking it low-key i
do have an event to go to tonight um for
spritz which i'm excited about then i
think other than that i might go to
actually the rodeo is at uh madison
square garden this weekend
1 000 go
yeah but other than that like no crazy
plans i'm sure you're what like tripping
on acid doing crazy things yeah brew and
i were going to experiment with
mushrooms because we've heard some
really
we've heard some really good things and
bruno said to me he's like hey mom i
want to get in touch with my inner self
and i was like i heard we can do
mushrooms we could do ayahuasca and he
was like mom let's start small so brew
and i will be tripping balls this
weekend and we're so fun
yeah we're really really excited but
speaking of the rodeo actually first of
all you have to go now that you've said
that and i know that that's happening in
new york city like if you don't go i
will be disappointed in you i know
second of all i caught up on yellowstone
last night the last three episodes this
season finale was last week and so i'm
just like in a rodeo state of mind so
for that reason you extra have to go who
are you going to go with
well i really only go places with one
person and that's brian do you invite
the snatcher she would love to by the
way i have made no plans like brian
brought it up and he was like should we
go and i was like yes but he's in
pennsylvania there's snow so there's
like a lot of things to consider before
we make the decision the first night is
tonight
i don't hear anything that needs to
there's snow
the snow by the way the snow by the way
could not be more gorgeous
it is like i know it's before the snow
turns brown and claudia like has a
meltdown well you know what that's
actually one of the good things about
living in a bunker is like while i
didn't see the snow before christmas i
also have not subjected to
the brown duty slush that comes directly
after like the gorgeous winter
wonderland
right now it snowed overnight in new
york and we are still in a winter
wonderland like the trees have just like
the icicles hanging off it's honestly
stunning you should take a look around
before it turns
brown and anyways it's not the sort of
snow that's going to keep you from going
a few blocks to madison square garden
that's not what i was saying rude i was
saying like brian's in pennsylvania so
he might not want to trek back to the
city like when there's tons of snow
that's what i was saying
got it yeah i think it's like rodeo or
pennsylvania but you but even if brian
doesn't want to go you should go with
the snatcher maybe you guys can like
find some cowboys
have you ever seen the longest ride
i have i'm not currently in the market
for a cowboy maybe that changes by
tomorrow but for now i'm all set ben
would understand
i've got my jewish cowboy which ben
would understand
100
no i'm not stopping until you and
snatcher are at the rodeo at madison
square garden like getting a hat thrown
to you from the arena and wearing some
assless chaps
yet to be a hundred percent honest with
you and our audience i'm not entirely
sure what a rodeo is like that's bull
riding
i think it's a lot of different events a
lot of different cowboy events you know
there's
um what was i watching yesterday there's
like the bull riding then there was the
guy who was like dancing on the horse a
little bit
i hope there's a performer
at msg i wonder what company houston
rodeo is
legendary like people
lizzo like people perform selena carter
yes i'm hoping i get some of that
you'll never know if you don't go
so i'm thinking it through and if any
new york steens are listening right now
and didn't have plans this weekend and
feel inspired to go to the rodeo like
please let us know how it is
yeah i didn't know that there was a
thing like that was a thing that the
rodeo partook at madison square garden i
had no idea i'd never heard of it and it
just goes to show like something
new you learn something new every day
about this about this incredible city
oh god um i am thinking it through yes
so that's what i might do this weekend
but i did want to share that i slept 12
hours last night 9 30 to 9 30. wow and
there is really
nothing like sleep i think sleep is
magical
and it's life-changing and i honestly
think i don't do it enough
okay i mean not really your hottest take
sleep is like
everything of the sort it really like
solves problems health like i mean a
million different things and i don't
know that i would say that you don't
sleep enough
no i wouldn't say that either but i
would say that sometimes i prioritize
other things over sleep whether that's
like watching tv scrolling on tick tock
going out and i just think on my list of
priorities i gotta get sleep up there
like a little higher sleep is really
high for me and it's about to it's about
to be bumped down
by the laws of nature which is a bummer
but i've had a really good run how old
i'm 29 i've had some really good sleeps
in my years and that's all you can ask
for so i'm glad that you enjoyed your
sleep i actually stayed up really late
last night for me
because i was i had to finish
yellowstone i was like i'm not gonna
yeah leave 40 minutes of the season
finale i got to know what happens and
i'm glad that i did it's such a good
show you know true degenerates like
myself who like
watch so much tv and lay in bed all day
like you're a real degenerate if you
like make sure throughout the day when
you're watching tv that you will get
done with this season or this episode or
this movie at a certain time so as not
to impact your sleep schedule like when
you're as lazy as that like i'm
constantly scheduling my days when it
comes to television
got it i don't really understand um
okay so like
so if it's seven o'clock and i've been
watching a tv show all day and i just
finished season two i like will not
start season three because i know that
puts me in a difficult position towards
midnight
i think that's not degeneracy i feel
like that's proper planning
well you know what i'm a proper planning
queen and like it's not i mean we watch
a lot of tv and stuff but it's not like
we stay like people really do stay up to
like 3 4 a.m watching yeah i stayed up
last night till about 12 45 but i don't
usually fall asleep before 12 45 so
usually i'm just like laying around but
it was weird to be watching tv so late
do you feel like the way that i see it
is like there's a hierarchy amongst
people who watch tv and the people who
watch tv on their computers in my mind
are like the biggest tv degenerates like
they stay up till 6 a.m watching you
know reruns of pretty little liars
i don't know it just depends on where
you're at in your life like when i was
in college i used to watch all my tv on
my computer well i didn't really have an
alternative
no no i really
but it's like now i have a tv in my
bedroom you can see it why would i ever
watch tv on my computer yeah no
something about me is that like i've
never been in a place in my life where i
didn't have a television within four
feet of me
even in college like your freshman year
dorm
no i if you read my book jackie i
literally talk about this tv that i had
that changed my life how did it change
your life
it was i was the only person
really in my entire dorm but let alone
on my floor who had a tv and it like
made me special and i got it for
literally thirty dollars it was like
refurbished from best buy and it was
really small but it was like life
changing and that's when like me and all
my friends were like super into
housewives i mean i still am but like
for us it was like an event everyone
would come over and it really made me
like the center of my social circle got
it so they were using you
yeah
and
that's when i started watching friends
and it was because like at nyu they had
cable and if you like got one of those
cables into the wall you had like six
basic channels and it was always on
those basic channels and i was like you
know what
that's what i'm gonna watch but i also
had tlc and that's when i started
watching breaking amish which was a
life-changing journey for me as well
nice
nice it's all available in my book which
actually i'm so glad you brought that up
jackie um we're coming up on the one
year anniversary of my book release
which means that my book is coming out
in paperback on january 25th you can
pre-order it now on amazon um but i just
wanted to let you guys know that like
we're doing another re-release like we
are gonna be thirsting out um at all
times of day
that's very exciting and speaking of
reading i forgot to share with you guys
yesterday that the new episode of the
red hat dropped it is so good and funny
like i was thinking back on some of the
things we were talking about like i was
literally laughing out loud um so
whether you read the book or you didn't
read the book i think you would enjoy
the episode and it's never too late to
become a redhead the first week of the
new year is the perfect time and i think
that this book and episode is a great
entry point for someone who's not like a
voracious reader also i'm so excited for
our next book because first of all we're
skipping over me it's supposed to be my
choice but because we're missing a month
for my maternity leave i didn't want any
of the other girls to miss their month
so i took one for the team plus my books
last year were the worst books so that's
my punishment
but that's actually
a really crazy statistic
yeah no like the votes are in my book's
work they don't like your choice and no
they don't and i don't like my choice so
i was actually really happy to have the
pressure off
uh but so rebecca chose a book so her
doorman she said read over 400 books in
2021
over 400 books well you know what
certain jobs make it
like really they encourage reading and
adornment especially if you're like a
late night doorman where there's not a
lot of action perfect time to pick up a
book right so she said to him
what is one book that you would
recommend that that i should choose for
the book club and so she got his choice
so like out of 400 books this is the
best one i'm actually really excited to
read it wow i love that selection
process isn't that a fun fact
oh also another fun fact i don't know if
you were watching but last night
jeopardy amy won again but this time
like she was challenged there was a guy
who was so interesting he's a delivery
truck driver and i'm telling you if amy
wasn't on he would have won like he and
he might have gone on like a short three
or four episode run like he was really
smart and if he was up against anyone
else i think he actually might have had
like a really good chance
um
even though like he did [ __ ] it up at
the end but still it was it was really
interesting and so she's almost at a
million she's at 980 000
and
she killed it
wow that is really exciting i'm sorry to
this man even though i know his name is
jeff because i watch your instagram
stories but it's actually pronounced
geoff geoff yes i did
i did see that i wonder now that i'm
thinking like so caught up in names like
baby names what
compels someone to spell
off
as opposed to jeff so can i tell you how
i like imagine someone thinks it through
sure
okay so let's say they like the name
jeff for whatever reason they think it's
a good name it's a family name it's a
nice name and it's just free
is it also
geoffrey
like is his full name joffrey
yes i think it's geoffrey a hundred
percent okay chia free baratheon but
there is something somewhat common about
the name it's very popular so maybe the
parent is like well i want to honor this
name for whatever reason like it's a
family name
but i want my son to still be like a
unique girly girl
so
then they're like well let's spell it
differently gee off
i don't know
no you know what i'm sure the real
reason is like it probably hails from a
different country
where different letters are used and
like it's just the spelling is different
based on where you come from
also a good option but i'm sticking with
my theory okay
maybe now like
maybe back then that's how g-off got
into the mix because it was like you
know the different letters it's a
combination of both of our theories but
today people go with g-off because it's
like a little bit more
special than jeff
right and like you just don't want your
kid to be jeff like in a in a group full
of like you know
brandon
you know everyone's like making up names
these days so i love my friend brandon
he is just like the coolest guy
everyone's like brandon this
i was trying to think of like one of
those names but i couldn't like
if you know anyone named brandon please
send them this episode well you know i
have a special place in my heart for a
name like that because back in my
snapchat days one of my most popular
characters was a woman named randy lynn
and she's still somewhere inside of me
yeah for sure but there is a very big
difference between brandy lynn and
brandlin
i was trying to like no i know what you
mean like the board of names honestly
yes yes
the meme the meme yes yes we all know
yeah which i just none of the names on
the on the meme are coming to mind
that's why i said bren lin we'll have to
post it um
but everyone knows that meme yeah
um so we've got a great show for you
guys today um you know i hate i i agree
with what you said yesterday like i hate
when we have like the same story every
day but there's been an enormous
development
of it all yeah there's a lot to talk
about in the kim
pete kanye julia realm and we're just
going to round out the week the way that
we started it i'm sorry talking about
these four people because there have
been major developments and
it just it is what it is yeah but i
agree and hopefully you know everyone
will take like a long nap after this and
just chill out
and we don't hear from them for a while
but like as long as we're hearing from
them we're going to be talking about
them it's what we do and luckily these
are people that we absolutely love and
adore
you know it's not like you have a lot of
thoughts on
it's not like a love triangle between
you know a big [ __ ] like people that are
yeah it's tough when there's like a
trending news story and on a personal
level like i just couldn't give less of
a [ __ ] about these people and i would
love to just not talk about them but
they're like so famous and it's like the
biggest thing going on in the world so
let's be grateful that the biggest story
for this last week is something we're
actually
interested in and motivated by yeah and
is about our favorite people so i guess
without further ado
where are you where is dew
um
dew is with his father because
like when we're in new york when we were
away for um the holiday was theo up my
butt or what like he was obsessed with
me oh my god it was like low-key
annoying up your butt and around the
corner
in the toy chest
did other kids used to say that or was
that like an australian family thing no
it's
i don't know does anybody know where mom
is up your butt around the corner in the
toy chest were we the only ones who said
toy chests like we definitely
i
up here about around the corner is a
saying
but in the toy chest but like until we
have a toy chest uh we had a lot of
different chests but we had a chest full
of all of our like costumes yeah
but um
a toy chest is not like a term that we
really used a lot so i feel like we
didn't make it up
do let us know did you grow up with the
toy chest of it all
yeah
anyways now without further ado oh wait
sorry so what i was saying was when we
were away like theo like i could not get
arrested he was like kind of clingy and
now that we're back in new york he's
back to not [ __ ] with me whatsoever
obsessed with ben except you know i love
to talk about me and ben's communication
issues when it comes to theo you know
this week twice theo got fed twice i
know two breakfast tigs
he was two breakfast tigs and then he
was two dinner tags
and yesterday
we had a major music miscommunication
theo did not get fed breakfast
and we were like arguing i think at the
end of the day like it was my fault but
it was a a
a mistake that anyone could have made
mm-hmm
that happened over here once bryce
didn't get traumatizing you feel like
such a negligent piece of [ __ ] yeah and
it's like why didn't you say something
no i know and it's like
it just i actually felt so bad
that that's rough but you know what
after like tbt and tdt
he was totally balanced nbt
was due was do do
if you follow that you get an a for
today's math class if you understood
what the [ __ ] we just said like
bless your heart yeah
okay now without further ado
here are the fast type stories that you
need to know before you wake up and take
a bite out of your morning toast
and today's sponsor is very appropriate
because we were just giving into the dew
of it all it's fuzzy if you have a pet
you know they're part of your family and
fuzzy knows that there's nothing that
compares to coming home to a wiggle but
or waking up to soft purrs and that we
want to keep our pets healthy and make
them as happy as they make us and fuzzy
is a telehealth service for pet parents
that offers 24 7 access to personalized
pet care from veterinary professionals
so from everyday questions to the middle
of the night emergency fuzzy has the
answers pet parents need through live
chat and virtual pet consultations
available to you 24 hours a day seven
days a week fuzzy can answer your pet
questions big and small urgent and
everyday
they can also recommend the exact right
products for your pet
all of which are hand-picked by their
established team of veterinary
professionals and available at discounts
exclusive to fuzzy members
so i actually used fuzzy a bunch before
they were sponsored during the pandemic
because like couldn't go anywhere and it
was the easiest thing ever that now i'm
just like a full-time customer i think
it's the best thing ever and i'm like
the type of pet mom who like bugs out
over the smallest thing so just be able
to pick my pick up my phone and get some
peace of mind is really a life-changing
service definitely and right now fuzzy
is offering our listeners a free
seven-day trial membership go to
yourfuzzy.com toast to sign up today so
that's a free seven-day trial at
y-o-u-r-f-u-z-z-y
dot com slash toast and for a limited
time fuzzy is all for also offering a
special discount of twenty dollars off
of any of your pets product needs
whether that's meds supplements food and
more with the promo code toast so make
sure you're going to yourfuzzy.com toast
for your free trial with access to 24 7
personalized pet care and vet
recommended products so your fuzzy dot
com slash toast and promo code toast for
that 20 off uh 20 discount excuse me
and today's episode is also sponsored by
gem nearly 90 of americans are nutrient
deficient there's a massive
misconception that just because you're
healthy your body doesn't need anything
extra and our food system today is
broken so even if you eat a well-rounded
diet it's impossible to get all the
nutrition that you need and gem is
solving this issue by filling the gaps
in your diet with the daily nutrition in
one delicious bite because gem believes
in eating your vitamins because food
can't fit in a pill it's not a snack and
it's not a vitamin as you know them
today capsules pills gummies etc it's
real food designed to make you happy and
healthy and it's just a really easy way
to make sure that like you're completely
well-rounded if you try to be like super
super healthy or even if you don't
really care
adding one thing to your diet it can
make a massive massive improvement to
your overall health
and it can be really hard to find the
right thing and that's why gem is so
great it's free of synthetics artificial
ingredients added sugar soy gluten and
animal products it's just good food
plants only packed into a bite it's made
up of a blend of over 15 whole food
ingredients that give you all the
essential vitamins minerals adaptogens
superfoods prebiotics and probiotics to
address our modern lifestyle needs and
key deficiencies helping with total mind
and body support so you'll actually feel
like a real visible difference once you
get into gem for me i find especially
towards later in the day like there's a
cloud around my brain i don't have like
a lot of mental clarity and i found like
that's one of the biggest improvements
for me just like an overall wellness of
my mind body soul spirit
and if you want to check out gem and try
their seasonal favorite citrus ginger
daily essential for yourself we have a
special offer for the morning toast
go to
gemvitamins.com
tmt or enter code tmt at checkout for 30
off your first order that's
gemvitamins.com tmt for 30 off your
first order thank you jim for being
today's sponsor and you guys will thank
us it's a premium really easy way to
just start taking better care of
yourself in 2021 oh 2022 excuse me
that's like you know everyone's
resolutions so check out gem wonderful
okay our first story
kanye's new lady love has written an
article for interview magazine complete
with pictures about their second date
it's called date night now and it's
incredibly illusory i'm sorry okay
first of all it's only two paragraphs so
like i really actually just want to read
it because um tldr even though it's not
long at all because i like sat down this
morning with my breakfast and i was like
i'm gonna read what julia fox wrote for
interview magazine so i read a
screenshot from not skinny but not fat
i'm like oh you know let me go read this
whole article that was it
it's an instagram caption about her
night with kanye
it was a a call that could have been an
email
yes she said i met yay in miami on you
no it was an email that could have been
a call because like i was nobody wants
to get on the phone i was expecting more
this was a slap this was a slap chat to
her at work about her date night it was
an email that could have been like a
snap message no no no it was a snap
message that could have been an email
like this is so short is lengthy
it should have been lengthy if you're
writing an article like everyone's
sitting down two different things we're
saying two different things you're
writing an article everyone's sitting
down to read it and it's uh a snap
message and okay and my overall like
message here is that it didn't need to
be an article
got it yeah we were saying the same
thing but differently yes she said i met
yay in miami on new year's eve and it
was an instant connection okay they've
known each other for six days when she
wrote this
his energy is so fun to be around he had
me and my friends laughing dancing and
smiling all night we decided to keep the
energy going and fly back to new york
city to see slave play yay's flight
landed at six and the play was at seven
and he was there on time i was impressed
after the play we chose to do dinner at
carbone which jackie ashrae still has
never been to and her sister claudia did
not drop off pasta even though she said
that maybe she would
yeah but wait um what day did they go
out they went out so we reported that on
wednesday
they went out tuesday night
i was at carbon on wednesday yeah yeah
which is she said which is one of my
favorite restaurants obviously i
wouldn't know
at the restaurant yay directed an entire
photo shoot for me while people dined
the whole restaurant loved it and
cheered us on while it was happening
after dinner yay had a surprise for me i
mean i'm still in shock yay had an
entire hotel suite full of clothes it
was every girl's dream come true it felt
like a real cinderella moment i don't
know how he did it or how he got all of
it there in time but i was so surprised
like who does things like this on a
second date or any date everything with
us has been so organic i don't know
where things are headed but if this is
any indication of the future i'm loving
the ride okay
and then there's like an episode of the
bachelor
there's a series of photos that you know
are the ones the photo shoot that she's
referencing and some of them are like
pretty intimate between her and kanye
some of them are just like her being his
like fashion girly all dolled up and
like very moody aesthetic so
what is so let me just say one thing
okay
because for me like this is so tacky and
so corny and like not cute at all but i
just want to say like if kim was the
subject of all of this i would have been
like oh man this is everything like yes
i wish that was me
i mean my
confusion is like she got like it sounds
like she was out at a club with her
friends in my and like this girl just
seems like a regular like instagram like
pop culture girly she's like wait
wait i couldn't agree more
because to put it lightly
if you don't know who this person is and
most of us don't
the equivalent of kanye going out and
having this whole situation with this
girl is literally like honey going out
with you she has no idea
i was going to say like going out with
margo ash right like margot is in miami
for new year's eve and all of a sudden
her and her friends get kanye's
attention they're flying to new york
they're going to carbon all this happens
in six days and then margot takes to
this um
magazine she goes on the morning toast
and then talks about it so like
first of all i'm just happy for this
girl because how exciting and like i'm
yeah i think it's actually pretty cool
of kanye he's always saving like the
most serious people people who probably
don't even have instagram and like and
now he's just dating like a toaster it
feels like okay and so really the best
part of all of this i saw on instagram
liz height found a podcast so she has a
podcast
and at the end of last year she did like
a 2021 recap of all the crazy things
that happened in pop culture with her
co-host and they literally went on like
a 10-minute round about the kardashians
both of them like how they've been
obsessed since day one since before it
was cool they were talking about the
tristan drama they were out here
defending chloe talking about how sad
they were about kim and kanye like it's
actually extremely weird
i saw that too so that's what i'm saying
she's just like a girly about town and
like this amazing thing has happened and
i'm just so worried like where did her
and kanye go from here did he approve of
this article
part of me feels a part of me feels like
yes because of the photos like maybe he
wanted these pictures out there like
they're pretty cool and like they're you
know
his vibe the outfits and everything but
it's only six days in i'm worried that
you know
i'm worried it's over before it starts
so i was also extremely curious about
the approval from kanye like was this a
joint venture did she go rogue i'm very
curious about that too i'm also
interested
in the dynamics of this relationship
because the way that i'm seeing it is
like this is the biggest fairy tale the
best thing that'll ever happen like
julia like this is a once in a lifetime
thing a million girls that wish that
they would this would happen to them
but for kanye i'm like worried that this
is like a strategic move very public
trying to get kim's attention while
she's like you know involved with pete
and i'm worried that if that's what it
is like julia's like falling head over
heels in love with like who wouldn't
like this prince charming and for kanye
like this is just like a move
perhaps but i mean i think for her
one if it's a move i i would think that
she knows that like behind the scenes
like maybe that this is just like we're
having fun we're hanging out and we're
going to be public about it
and she's just you know having the time
of her life i don't think that he would
be like pretending to be in love with
her
if
you know like in private
if those weren't his intentions i'm just
worried i think he's a very like he's
very honest i think we could say about
kanye he's not a fan i think he's also
like an empath you know he's sensitive
to other people's feelings yeah so i
just i mean i don't know if they'll ever
go out again i hope that they do i can't
imagine that she did all of this without
his
consent knowing
so
i'm just gonna go ahead and say
okay
yeah it was very
um it was jarring to see
at first
but now that i've debriefed i still
think it's weird but i'm like happy for
this girl i'm just very worried about
her you know
i'm not
i'm not i feel like
this at worst is just going to be like a
fun anecdote and it best could be a
great love story
100
also there was something so weird her
and pete davidson did a photo shoot
together a few years ago
for a different magazine and which like
is only weird because if she was like a
an actual famous person you know famous
people meet each other all the time but
she's like not she's definitely like
trying like she's on her way up but
it's just really it's not like just it's
not like just like a celebrity thing
like it was
it's weird oh yeah a really weird i want
to say coincidence but you never know
well i'm just like happy for her i hope
she's having fun you know i think she's
this was probably the like the coolest
week of her life i hope it continues and
you know what i love the content at
least we got some pictures that's all we
are ever asking for
yeah just for me like the biggest um
question still remaining is you know
kanye's involvement in this
very public thing i don't think she
would go rogue i don't think i would
hope not yeah
i don't but i just don't think so so
also like did you see kim and pete are
already back from the bahamas yes that's
another story okay okay okay and you
know we can just segue into that and
then we'll come back we're going to just
like circle back to columbus
because he's making other news unrelated
oh
next up kim and pete are back from the
bahamas wearing the same clothes that
they were wearing in the
iconic temeronic pictures from yesterday
that we talked about she is wearing the
black top and the big jeans and he is
wearing the sweatsuit and the letterman
jacket which is really [ __ ] confusing
tmz has the pictures they're hopping off
the plane in
la wearing those outfits
what i realized they were wearing the
same outfit yeah so i have just so many
questions first of all it feels like you
know they were in the middle of their
vacation and they had to they were
called home that's because this trip was
five seconds 24 hours but yeah maybe it
was always meant to be that short but
bahamas to la is like a pretty far right
that's a long time it's like two and a
half hours they could have gone to cabo
if they really just wanted like a one
night vacation
i'm so confused i can't believe they're
wearing the same outfits i did not put
that together but then i started
thinking like
the outfits were so misplaced when we
saw them coming off of that other boat
that maybe
maybe all along they were on their way
to the airport also the other boat that
they were coming off of kind of looked
like one of those
charter boats that you take to get to
the airport from whatever island that
you're staying on
do you know what i mean
so are you saying that the pictures we
saw of them
yesterday were actually them leaving
i don't know i don't know what their
intent was i don't know if they the
pictures that they saw that we saw me
they were going to lunch and then all of
a sudden they had to like it was an you
know really
last-minute flight home you're a hundred
percent on so something like there is a
connection between the bizarro outfits
and this very quick 24-hour trip
yeah and so i think the rational part of
my mind is like the these were never
intended to be beach vacation outfits
they were always going to the airport i
mean he's wearing a backpack that's like
an airport move and i'm wearing a fleece
a wolf fleece jacket in the sun on the
beach yeah and kim's wearing jeans
enormous jeans nor machine so like maybe
she never planned on wearing jeans to
the beach and we won't be doing that in
two years thank the lord
jackie you are so smart i'm just i'm
working with the clues
you're no this is literally we're
playing clue and you're 100 right but
also noteworthy is the fact that he went
back to la with her oh that is
noteworthy and he was at a um
hockey game last night without kim
obviously
people do so much in a day i know but so
that's why when everyone's like you have
the same 24 hours in a day as kim
kardashian well i don't have the same
plane and the same budget and the same
as staff yeah no i was delayed i was
going through security and then and then
i had two and then i had to take a
shuttle to the uber pickup okay so if i
am
if i'm coming home from the bahamas
i'm not going to a hockey game that
night here's why one i didn't fly
private so i still have to go through
security
two i didn't have like you know an
escort meet me at the plane take me
directly to my home maybe even a
helicopter no i stood in a taxi line for
an hour and then i hit traffic which i
just feel like rich people they don't
hate traffic i don't think like traffic
applies to celebrities i always think
about that like i just don't think it it
happens and then when i got home like i
had to do my laundry and unpack i didn't
have like a team of maids to do that so
by the time the hockey game actually
started i'm probably not even home yeah
i think that rich people obviously hit
traffic unless they're taking a
helicopter not rich celebrities sorry
but when they get to
like the party doesn't start until they
get there so they're never late because
it's like it didn't happen yet
that is so true they're not like
stressed about the traffic because it's
like everyone there is waiting for them
right so it's like they don't have the
same anxiety of like i'm missing
everything
you're making amazing calls today like
really just one after the other
thank you thanks claudia
no you're so right like that's my goal
like to be like so fun and cool that
like
really it's not fun like till i get
there but alternate perspective is like
you could have that like that energy
it's all on you like if you didn't get
stressed out by traffic you were like i
don't want to be at a party that i'm not
out yet anyway
then perhaps traffic would be less
stressful
yeah but like i have too much like
insecurity and fomo i'm like right now
but i have to be there it's like
something that maybe you could work out
within yourself i need to work on yeah
yeah
goals for 2022.
i can't believe they're back i can't
believe that he went to a hockey game
and i'm like tired thinking about the
last 24 hours for them i know and i'm
like stressed thinking about that outfit
on the plane like
i can't when you know like it looked
like at fur when the pictures we saw
they were getting off of some sort of
like seaplane that's what i'm saying
like it looks like a boat that's like
it's not a fabulous day on a yacht like
it's a boat that takes you from a to b
because you got to get to the airport
let me take a look at that picture again
it has like uh yeah it's a boat it's not
like a sea plane and there was like
people behind hot on those boats there's
people behind them who are also wearing
jeans fellow travelers
yeah
it's not like you know
leo and santro pay like right right
right and that's why yesterday's
pictures were so disappointing because
that's what i would have wanted to see
from them oh my god breaking news sydney
pottier the first black man to win an
oscar titan of cinema has passed away oh
my goodness i started getting um like
people notifications
from their app
no from like apple news
oh oh no and i just have to say i
thought it would be like
i thought it would keep me on top of
things and i only selected like hardcore
breaking news
i thought it would keep me more up to
date but like it's literally my job like
they're telling me about things i
figured out 30 minutes ago
yeah no
if you have apple news notifications on
like do yourself a favor and turn them
off also even if you say like hardcore
breaking news like they take their
creative liberties with that and all of
a sudden like you're getting a breaking
news recipe
for a casserole
no you're totally right turn them off
it's so stressful it's only been like a
week so i'm gonna see
right now it's not bothering me but it's
not giving me like the
the joy of eve i thought it was gonna
give me
okay
okay anyways that's the latest with kim
and pete they're back in la they were
wearing those clothes i think they were
intended to be travel clothes the whole
time still like very unrelatable but
much more comprehensive understandable
than beach attire 100
great glad we got to the bottom of that
always
next up a little more kanye news
a little more kanye news that's brought
to you by helium10
are you seeking a career change an
alternative to the traditional nine to
five well if you're an entrepreneur who
wants to start a business or on their
own
sorry excuse me start a business on your
own terms check out helium10 they will
teach you how to build a thriving
ecommerce business from a to z you don't
need to invent a product their helium 10
tools help you find one and source it
you can tap into amazon's existing
customer base product demand and
shipping infrastructure to launch your
business and amazon will handle all the
shipping and the returns for you and
helium 10 is totally free to join and
it's not just a trial offer your free
account includes ongoing monthly access
to helium 10's most popular tools at no
cost to you helium 10 has been used by
over a million people worldwide and they
use it to sell goods directly to
amazon's customer base of 5 billion
shoppers
so if one of your resolutions this year
was like to get out of your work rut
start a side hustle helium 10 is really
the perfect thing it's basically a
business in a box they'll give you all
the tools tell you exactly what to do
you don't need to invent like a new
makeup brush they will just tell you how
to sell to amazon um customers amazon
handles all the torture of like the
shipping the handling the returns and
helium 10's just basically putting you
know money a business in your back
pocket you can work when you want and
from wherever
with the help of helium 10. join the
over 10 million excuse me join the over
1 million helium 10 customers
worldwide by signing up for a free
account at helium10.com
toast that's h h-e-l-i-u-m-10.com
toast should join the over 1 million
helium 10 users worldwide
helium10.com
toast does bruno want to start helium 10
he does he was feeling like very
impacted by your ad read and
as most people do he's feeling really
strongly about it
okay do you need to handle that while i
sing a song or something no i believe
that uh zach just cracked the door open
so bruno can go get his energy out cool
next story
kanye west confirms yeezy gap and
balenciaga collaboration
three in one or
three fur
early friday the artist formerly known
as kanye west took to instagram to
confirm the new collab by sharing an
excerpt from the associated legal
documents that have signed
contract by the gap yeezy supply and
valenciaga so
this is exciting is this balenciaga gap
prices or gap at balenciaga prices i
want to say it's balenciaga gap prices
because
that's what kanye's been doing for the
gap and a lot of you know high-end
brands do that
and we aside from fendi skins i haven't
seen like gap at balenciaga prices that
would be i mean that would be highway
robbery yeah no i think it'll be
like the balenciaga influence plus easy
as the connector gap as the distributor
manufacturer etc it sounds so cool i'm
not even gonna bother trying to get
anything like it's gonna be sold out in
45 seconds and i'm just honestly i don't
want to be let down yeah i mean zach is
sometimes good at
um taking that stuff out so maybe if
he's like
trying to get anything for himself i'll
be like get me anything
to get me something too extra large
but yeah i unless it's like really
honestly fendi skims i can only you know
set so many alarms yeah
and you can only be like first on for so
many things and i feel like
considering there's a lot of stuff that
i like want i feel like i
do okay out there you know
it brings me back to like the kylie lip
kit days i know i was actually just
thinking that too and i feel like you
know throughout the years i've gotten a
lot of the stuff that i have
wanted from these sort of drops so you
can't have everything and i just i don't
think i'll be able to get gap easy
balenciaga
and that's either
because i think it's like
i think it's probably more in demand
than like fendi skims
oh yeah given the price point most
likely yeah no but even like just kanye
and i'm assuming it's going to be like
unisex vibes
and also like the
spandex kim vibe it's not for everyone
but then kim like was being
revolutionary and having fendi going up
you know to sizes they've never even
heard of yeah
so that was iconic
those were good times except i'm still
upset about the dress that i ordered
that then my order was canceled and in
the time that it they told me that it
was canceled i could have gone to the
store and gotten it
and i went to the store and i was like
oh i ordered that dress i'm so excited
big dope big dope you're not getting it
big [ __ ]
like literally literally it's really
[ __ ] upsetting but i don't want to
complain because i know kim has a lot on
her plate of course of course of course
and this is not her plate
this is not my fight
okay well in the salt lake city reunion
yesterday did you see oh no i didn't how
were the looks i'm scared to ask i
didn't see looks yet i just saw andy
posting like his cards a video of him
and actually he didn't even show lisa
probably like so as not to spoil the
look he was just doing like a baby
gorgeous
riff with her
what's baby gorgeous
oh my god like like in the housewives
community it like went viral when it was
probably a scene you fast-forwarded
because lisa was just picking her son up
from school and it was like so
uninteresting but he gets in the car
she's like hi baby gorgeous and everyone
was like baby gorgeous baby gorgeous
that's fine i missed you
that's real that's actually really funny
and it's actually crazy how much lisa
has grown on me this year no i know but
still not enough to take the lead but no
one has no one has if if i had to choose
it would be meredith but of course lisa
was someone i couldn't even look at like
i'm like this woman yeah no i totally
agree
are you ready for our next story which
is some apt casting news
captain news
no
no okay no sorry cool okay cassie i'll
just just go
just some act
an audrey hepburn biopic is in the works
at apple and you're not gonna guess
who's playing her but when i tell you
you're gonna be like oh my god yes let
me think okay but you're gonna have to
think give me an age range like how old
is cat is audrey hepburn okay no i'll
give you the age i'll give you the age
of the actress though i don't think it
will help just because i don't think you
think about this person a lot
but um
she is 36 years old i'll give you some
clues that like 36 okay that's older
than i would have thought i'll give you
a little bit of trivia oh you want to do
charades no because most people listen
as a podcast
i'll give you a little bit of trivia
fact number one
has a equally i would say famous sibling
in the business too two
aaron foster
no aaron faster will not be playing the
role of audrey hepburn
okay so she is a
more than one is it elizabeth olsen
no very good guess
i only know of one famous sibling do you
want to know if it's a sister or a
brother
sure maggie gyllenhaal
no but oh my god because i was about to
write this biopic off immediately famous
sister okay both of them i would say it
depends what shows and movies you watch
but i would say they're equally famous
at least to me oh how random okay um if
i give you the next clue i think it will
probably okay do it tip you over they
come from a very wealthy family
i believe they have football ties
what
hold on let me think
okay so like i'm assuming their dad was
a football player
no like they own a football team i think
oh
okay oh oh yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
okay let me guess which one rooney mara
rooney mara
okay yeah she looks just like her jackie
you're right i've literally not thought
of rooney mara in 15 years and if you
never brought her up again and she never
crossed my mind like i would go to my
grave never thinking of her i know you
don't think about her also she is dating
joaquin phoenix
would have been my next clue which is
such a big marathon
you are oh right because you like the
teacher well i didn't like the teacher
because it was disgusting it was your
favorite
it was your favorite show i thought she
was great knit and i think she's really
like so cute
she was also really scares me a little
she was good in house of cards also
never watched it
um
you're not you would literally hate it
and i can't watch it now it's like what
are you supporting kevin and actually
you can't even find it anywhere no it's
definitely still on netflix
really i would have thought they took it
off like because of the shame no they i
mean it was their first big show they're
not gonna take it off and still so many
people love it and then they did the
last season without him so i think that
they thought that they you know redeemed
themselves even though everyone was like
get the [ __ ] out of here i still think
one of like the most interesting things
like to come out of the streaming wars
and just when we look back on the last
like five years of like how nobody
watches cable and the arch of like
streaming services offering old content
and then making their own and had like
the first original
streaming show really ever made with
house of cards i think it's like the
weirdest thing ever yeah but it was it
was really big and it was good at a time
but
not
i don't know i don't look back on it
fondly anyways rooney mara will be
playing the role of audrey hepburn in a
new biopic uh variety has confirmed
so
yeah i think she'll be great she really
looks like her and it's two pictures
like side by side let me see because i i
think in my mind they're both just like
brunette they're both like brunette with
like very angular faces
okay they just happen to choose a
picture of her like with a high button
where she does because so imagine with
hair and makeup imagine with audrey's
bangs like she's going to be literally
hurt to a tee that's exactly what i was
going to say hair and makeup because i
think of
rooney like on a personal level as being
edgy like borderline like frightening
and catherine hepburn is very like old
hollywood glamour soft feminine so i
will be very interested to see this hair
and makeup department and also rooney is
a really great serious actress so i
think like not only are getting someone
who looks exactly like the person but i
think
in the
art the her artistry will be on point as
well no she's extremely talented so i
think this is just like a win a casting
win that's true for this week just like
chris evans as gene kelly's imaginary
friend
yeah not
as passionate about that one no but i'm
i'm very passionate about this one i
think this is exciting and an audrey
hepburn biopic is always just a good
idea and he's welcome and i think like
for more people of our generation like
we all know audrey hepburn and everybody
has her quotes on their dorm wall but
like like that picture of her with the
pearl necklace like in spo on their
pinterest board right but like do you
even know her no no
and i think if you're gonna hang up a
picture of audrey hepburn like you
should have
required reading here's yeah so i think
it's all good i'm excited
yeah and that sounds like it'll be like
an oscar contender for sure
for sure
for sure
are you ready for a fifth and final
story that was hand-picked
for you
for you not for me like if i was hosting
with someone else i don't know that i
would have picked this story
well it's a good thing that it's the
fight
yikes all right
yikes it's the final story
[Music]
julia fox
what did kanye
know
about interview magazine
[Laughter]
okay it's the fifth and final story
brought to you by relatively famous
ranch rules which is a show we were just
talking about there's a brand new show
coming to e in january it's called
relatively famous ranch rules and it's
hilarious
they took eight kids who have celebrity
parents it's the hoff's daughter shaq's
kid billy bob thornton's son pat
benatar's daughter and a bunch of others
even easy's daughter is on the show
anyway they drop them onto a ranch and
help them out for the summer they're
supposed to quote save the ranch these
kids come from super privileged
backgrounds and they have zero life
skills and the show is amazing besides
all the crazy ranch stuff they have to
endure like breeding cattle and chasing
pigs around they have they have to
contend with each other's rich kid drama
because of course they all think they're
so special these kids are totally
unprepared for any of this they have
never even had to cook their own food
before and now they're being thrown into
a situation where they have to figure
out how to cope with real life and real
work for the first time in their lives
it's a lot for them as you can imagine
and the show is everything bad behavior
romance bromance hookups and the
occasional cattle drive it's relatively
famous ranch rules and it starts this
january only on a we were just talking
about the other day how it's such a good
concept for a show that is so funny and
i'm so glad now we know who the kids are
and i guess some of them have different
last names than their parents but right
that's a really great cast and also now
that i'm like having a yellowstone sized
piece of my heart missing this might
fill it honestly this is just the thing
just the thing okay our fifth and final
story which is for claudia directly
coca-cola is partnering with concepts i
know i know is partnering with
constellation brands to launch alcoholic
fresca cocktails
so ben told me this yesterday because
you know nothing flies in the alcohol
world without ben being notified right i
feel a little funny even talking about
it because obviously we're spritz
girlies
use code toast at sportssociety.com the
best product on the market and i stand
by that but that doesn't mean i can't be
open to other things no and like when
your favorite beverage is coming out
with an alcoholic version obviously you
have to try it
let me tell you why this is such a good
idea one because fresca in my mind is
like a really unique brand that's like a
part of obviously coca-cola like a
global but a lot of people like don't
drink it and if they do it's like always
with alcohol obviously a fresca and
tequila
is called it's like a fresquila
yeah but it's like an off-brand uh
paloma it's like a grapefruit tequila so
it's really really popular and it's like
a better version of sprite in my opinion
it has more flavors and i love it on its
own but most normal people drink it as a
cocktail and use it as a mixer so i
think that this is super super genius i
don't know what type of alcohol it's
going to be i really hope it's not like
a malt beverage like all these
spike seltzers are malt that's just like
malt is not it it's not like in my
opinion good um and i hope that they can
work on doing
this as a tequila brand because there's
a huge gap in the market you know that i
think it was anheuser-busch that was
working with travis scott for his cactus
they've just continued it given the
drama and i also just don't think it was
super popular what i saw people saying
was like it was actually disgusting um
so there's a gap in the market for like
a tequila thing so i think that they
should be tequila i really do
okay well it doesn't say here but um
the beverage will be a line of full
flavored spirit-based ready-to-drink
cocktails including fresca which is a
grapefruit and citrus-flavored soft
drink with zero calories the new name of
the
alcoholic fresco will be called fresca
mixed
okay i feel like they could have had a
little more fun with that like i agree
it's very big
yeah
yeah like fresca's just like a great
word that you could conjunct
it's like and else you could add on to
it like
fret
i don't want him
no
we'll get there hold on yeah but also if
we knew what was in it that would be
helpful because we could call it like
right fresquia we would know would be
like tequila fresca if you have a good
idea for a title of this cocktail drop
it in the comments yeah but i think that
this is really exciting just like one
it's a good idea to you love fresca and
you'll try it and three you know if it's
if it's really good like that's great if
it's not it sucks there's a waste
society head over from code toast to
society.com uh kotos but also spirit
society's wine base and there's no way
that this is gonna be wine based no so
they said spirit based which really
makes me think it's gonna be a tequila
base but and i understand why now that
i'm like in the biz it makes if you have
a a product that's like actually vodka
or tequila based there's like half the
locations you can't legally get into you
can't really be sold depending on the
state at like a 7-eleven a convenience
store or supermarket
yeah that's why these spike seltzers are
so popular you could sell it at a
[ __ ] cvs because it's really not
true alcohol it's malt which personally
doesn't agree with my stomach um because
it's a lot of chemicals
you know i really prefer to be like a
natural queen that's why i go with
sports society uh cotos the all-natural
um flavors and ingredients
yeah and
made in america based in sonoma
california so good real wine real
flavors
real people real
real
so but this is very exciting i'm not
delusional this is
has the potential to be huge yeah
i mean and that would be really great
for coca-cola because you know they're
this small startup brand right and they
like you know has a lot of tenacity they
could really use a win i would be really
happy for them you love to see other
small businesses
getting out there
building up
equity for themselves it's gorgeous in
the space yeah
you do so those are the fast five
stories i do feel like you needed to
know them as you head into this
wonderful first weekend of the new year
if you're going to a dinner party if
you're going to the rodeo you have what
to talk about and
what to ruminate on what to think about
i feel like we've asked a lot of big
questions this week you know we have we
have why would you name your son geoff
if you could name him jeff
so true something to think about
that's what we do here we give you guys
things to talk about and we really just
wanna i thought this was a great week of
toast i'm so glad we got our video up um
and i'm just really looking forward to
what the rest of the year has and
especially looking forward to this
weekend yeah i'm really jazzed about
this new interface i've been working on
some stuff like for myself to make my
experience more premium but i'm just
being shut down at every turn like i
tried to order a new computer
and um the apple is anybody else like
having heart change
wait horrible experiences with apple a
month ago i ordered airpods and in new
york like when you order from the apple
store they deliver it same day because
they're in two hours yeah my airpods
never arrived that day the next day a
week later they i finally like called
apple support and because it said it was
delivered and like they're just
gaslighting me they weren't delivered
fraudulent
finally i got someone on the phone and
they were like um you know a lot of
things are just being stolen in transit
and just not arriving to their desired
location i was like oh um okay greatest
city on earth i was like okay that's
really scary i hope everyone's okay and
i got my order cancelled but then i went
to order a new computer i was like you
know what i'm going to give apple a
chance again small company like just
want to support right right so important
to lift up small businesses shop local
so important to lift lift up the first
business that's worth a trillion dollars
in um history yeah no i felt really good
about that and then
my computer did not come that day of
course why would it fool me twice shame
on me and then the next day they just
canceled my order and they said no
you're not getting a new computer and
your your video is going to be blurrier
than claudius and that's how it's going
to stay
sounds like a former toaster works at
apple and is setting you up for failure
yeah no and so it's like am i going to
try a third time or what is my
alternative maybe it's time for adele a
pc
maybe i should get adele just lenovo
like because
i've heard great things about the
microsoft surface i don't know if it has
a camera
and that's a tablet right
yeah yeah it's a tablet i need like a
big honking computer i mean you would
think apple are the computer people but
what what do you do when you can't get a
computer no and now this is like just a
true testament to how much we rely on
apple and how it's like such like an
integral part of our lives
yeah so there's no other option like
there's really no competitor like no
offense like i'm not going pc like i'd
rather have no computer
maybe i should go i don't i just need a
[ __ ] computer so
i've heard good things about lenovo
okay it's a really weird spot to be in
100 like this isn't optional
also like you just could send zach to
the apple store i could
that that would be maybe my next my next
step but like
apple a trillion dollars you can't order
a computer online you can't get a
computer
you know apple could learn a thing or
two about running a business from us
totally
totally um well those were the fast five
i definitely feel so you needed to know
them there is no tv recap because
yesterday was
nothing on tv
and that is
i believe
our show it is our show i do feel like
for it could have been someone else's
but it wasn't it was awesome no i
actually don't think it could have been
anyone else's button yeah i know i know
thank you guys so much for listening to
the morning toast the millennial morning
show where we deliver the fast five
stories that you yes you need to know
before you wake up and take about out of
morning toast we are available on
youtube so if you're watching this on
youtube please feel free to subscribe
and give this video a thumbs up
we're also available as a podcast
anywhere podcast can be found so it's
spotify
itunes stitcher public radio i hope we
do catch box all the places so if you
listen to podcast find us the morning
toast and leave a five star review about
how beautiful stunning and smart we are
we hope you guys have an amazing weekend
stay safe enjoy the snow come see the
rodeo and we love you
love ya bye